اهلا بكم نحن الان داخل مطار الخرطوم
الدولي الذي دارت فيه الاشتباكات منذ
الخامس عشر من ابريل المنصرم دارت هذه
الاشتباكات وخلفت كثير من الدمار والخراب
ندخل الان الى صاله المغادره وهذه هي
الصاله الاساسيه التي كان يعبر من خلالها
الكثيرين الى وجهات العالم المختلفه نحن
الان داخل الصاله الرئيسيه للمغادره حيث
كان يقف هنا عدد من المسافرين
ويتجمعون لعمليات السفر واجراء عدد من
الاجراءات الرسميه للسفر في هذه في هذا
المكان كان يقف المسافرون
وتتم من خلالها الاجراءات الرسميه المتبعه
في صلاه السفر العالميه تشاهد هذا الدمار
وهذا الخراب الذي لحق بهذا المكان عدد
كبير من السيارات التي كانت تتوقف في مطار
الخرطوم تعرضت للحرق بشكل واضح جراء
الاشتباكات التي دارت منذ الخامس عشر
جبريل نشاهد ذلك من خلال هذه المشاهد وهذه
الصور الحصريه لقناتها العربيه والحدث من
امام صاله الحج والعمره ومن الناحيه
الشرقيه ننظر الى
مهبط الطائرات الرئيسي في مطار العاصمه
الخرطوم بحسب ما نشاهد لم يتضرر جراء
الاشتباكات العسكريه ولكن عدد من الطائرات
شاهدناها محروقه او محترقه بالشكل الكامل
هنا هي صاله الحج والعمره حيث يتجهز كثيره
جدا من المعتمرين والحاجين الى بيت الله
الحرام في كل عام ويخرجون من هذه الصاله
الى هذه السيارات التي تقف وتنقل كثير جدا
من
المسافرين الى الطائرات التي كانت تتوقف
في القرب من هذا المكان حتى عدد من
الشركات العامله في مطار الخرطوم نلاحظ ان
عدد من السيارات
محطمه بشكل جزئي وتوقفت بشكل كامل
الجوازات سفر وهواتف نق اله محطمه ولكن
هنا الصاله صاله الحج والعمره ما زالت
بخير لم تتحطم الجراء الاشتباكات العسكريه
التي دارت بين الجيش والدعم السريع في
الخامس عشر من ابريل المنصرين بعد 47 يوما
من القتال كنا معكم هنا داخل مطار الخرطوم
لقناتي العربيه والحدث عمار ابو شيبه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات